[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 13 avril voici le programme de
ce soir il nous fascine où il nous
effraie en tout cas elle bouscule nos
vies et certains secteurs d'activité
chat GPT le logiciel d'intelligence
artificielle est capable de vous sortir
un cours d'histoire de vous rédiger un
article de presse ou encore de vous
établir un régime alimentaire dans les
Yvelines l'équipe pédagogique du cours
griffon un organisme privé
d'enseignement à distance a décidé de
s'en servir on fait le point avec Xavier
du Bellay le fondateur du cours griffon
et si avec l'arrivée des beaux jours
vous vous remettiez à faire du sport
c'est en tout cas l'objectif d'Élancourt
la ville dans son printemps du sport au
programme des séances gratuites jusqu'en
juin pour encourager l'activité physique
tennis natation gymnastique ou encore
Street workout activité sportive en
plein air on en parle avec Thierry
Michel le premier le premier maire
adjoint de la commune d'Élancourt et
puis comme d'habitude le jeudi à
l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme spiritualité
écologie ou encore chasse aux œufs et
oui même si le week-end de Pâques est
passé vous pouvez toujours déguster des
chocolats les détails en fin d'émission
avec notre journaliste Gabriel Gontier
et en plateau avec moi Xavier du Bellay
bonsoir bonsoir alors je le disais à
l'instant vous êtes le fondateur du
cours gryffond un voisin le Bretonneux
et vous avez décidé de tester
l'intelligence artificielle chat GPT on
aura le temps d'en parler un peu plus
tard tout à l'heure mais avant
j'aimerais quand même que vous
présentiez un petit peu le cours griffon
qu'est-ce que c'est alors le fond c'est
un organisme d'enseignement à distance
que j'ai fondé il y a 10 ans
on est à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a
des élèves en France
partout en France et même dans le monde
entier on a à peu près 2400 élèves dont
un garçon à l'étranger aux États-Unis en
Angleterre en Europe un peu partout dans
le monde donc ce sont des enfants
français à expatriés et puis les trois
autres cartes sont en France et nous
prennent du CP à la Terminale soit en
soutien scolaire
soit en complément de scolarité quand
l'enseignement en classe est défaillant
sur un prophète absent soit un programme
qui n'est pas bouclé
soit encore ils peuvent nous choisir en
quand ils font de l'école à la maison
mais beaucoup d'enfants c'est pas
toujours très connu mais beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont obligés à l'école à
la maison une année deux années ils ont
besoin de cours et on est là et donc
vous vous êtes demandé si l'intelligence
artificielle chat GPT pouvait remplacer
les professeurs on en parlera un peu
plus tard dans cette émission avec nous
également sur le plateau Thierry Michel
bonsoir alors je le rappelle vous êtes
le premier ma adjoint à Élancourt la
Ville lance jusqu'en juin le printemps
du sport avec des séances de tennis de
gym ou de foot tout est gratuit quel est
l'objectif encourager la pratique
sportive oui la pratique sportive est
surtout de l'activité physique c'est
également la volonté de soutenir le
tissu associatif qui joue un rôle
essentiel dans la ville et puis c'est
ouvert des infrastructures
la population qui doit bénéficier de
tout ce que la ville peut mettre à leur
disposition on aura l'occasion d'en
parler un peu plus tard dans les détails
avec nous également deux journalistes de
la rédaction de TV 78 Régine ralech et
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir bonsoir alors
Gabriel comme d'habitude le jeudi vous
venez nous présenter vos idées de sortie
dans les Yvelines de quoi allez-vous
nous parler ce soir tout à fait Mathilde
on parlera notamment d'un événement à
Triel-sur-Seine avec la venue d'un moine
Shaolin alors un événement qui risque
d'intéresser les fans de kung fu mais
aussi les curieux vous le verrez et donc
ce sera enfin d'émission restez bien
avec nous Régine vous vous allez nous
présenter les informations du jour à
retenir dans les Yvelines dans cette
émission également la fête de la
librairie indépendante nous serons avec
le gérant du pavé du canal pour en
parler mais aussi le traditionnel quiz
sur quel thème Grégory canalet va nous
challenger ce soir vous le verrez tout à
l'heure ce sera à découvrir enfin des
missions mais avant je vous propose de
jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
demain matin la pluie sera bien présente
sur une bonne partie des Yvelines seul
le secteur de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines restera au
sexe selon Météo France au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 5 degrés à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles dans
l'après-midi la pluie c'est en sur tout
le département et côté température
comptait environ 8 à 7 degrés en moyenne
et demain nous fêterons la saint Maxime
Le Point maintenant sur les informations
du jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous régénéralesh on
commence ces informations du jour avec
un point sur la grève contre la réforme
des retraites et oui une douzième
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites s'est déroulées
aujourd'hui partout en France et ce elle
avait du Conseil constitutionnel qui
doit se prononcer sur la réforme des
retraites côté éducation à l'échelle de
l'académie de Versailles 3% des
professeurs dans les écoles primaires se
sont grévistes ils étaient près de 7%
dans les collèges et 5% dans les lycées
au niveau de des transports le trafic
était quasi normal avec quelques
perturbations à noter sur les lignes j u
n et sur le RER C et enfin du côté des
stations services les pénuries d'essence
restent encore importantes pour le
département des Yvelines c'est 30 % des
stations-service qui sont en difficulté
aujourd'hui marque aussi le coût d'envoi
pour la déclaration des revenus dès ce
jeudi 13 avril les contribuables peuvent
désormais compléter leur déclaration
pré-remplie sur le site impôts.gouv pour
les habitants du département des
Yvelines vous avez jusqu'au 8 juin pour
faire vos déclarations mais pour les
usagers qui n'ont pas accès à Internet
ou qui ne sont pas en mesure de remplir
la déclaration en ligne la déclaration
papier devra être envoyée au plus tard
le 22 mai et une bonne nouvelle pour les
contribuables le barème des impôts et
désormais indexés sur l'inflation
conséquence plusieurs millions de
Français bien payé moins d'impôts cette
année et on poursuit ces informations du
jour avec un rapport sur la pollution
régime vie Airparif l'Observatoire de la
qualité de l'air en Île-de-France a
présenté son bilan annuel ce jeudi ce
qu'il en ressort c'est une amélioration
de la qualité de l'air mais pas
suffisamment
respectueuse en tout cas des seuils
recommandés par l'OMS donc
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé mais
alors comment expliquer cette
amélioration tout d'abord par des
conditions météorologiques ont été
globalement favorables pour la
dispersion des polluants on a également
connu un hiver plus doux et des
températures plus clémentes ce qui a
permis de limiter l'usage et les
émissions du chauffage en revanche un
polluant lui continue d'augmenter c'est
l'ozone ce gaz se forme sous l'effet de
la chaleur et augmente avec le
réchauffement climatique un mot de
transport à présent régime vit le 14
mars dernier Île-de-France mobilité
mettait à disposition des voyageurs le
lien un espace de dédommagement le but
recevoir un remboursement pour compenser
les dégradations de services des
transports en commun sur l'année 2022 la
date butoir était fixée à demain
vendredi 14 avril mais vous avez
jusqu'au vendredi 20 avril pour faire
vos demandes et enfin Régine vous avez
une bonne nouvelle pour les cyclistes
effectivement les tarifs des parkings
vélo évolu si vous êtes détenteur d'un
forfait Navigo Annuel les parkings
sécurisés sont désormais gratuits à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quatre garçons
concernés celle de plaisir Villepreux
trappes et Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et
bien merci beaucoup Régine rage pour ces
informations et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous avez vu une information
ou une image qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
[Musique]
il fait très souvent l'actualité il est
même souvent perçu comme une menace par
de nombreux corps de métiers le logiciel
d'intelligence artificielle chat GPT
fait beaucoup parler de lui déjà utilisé
par certains élèves pour rédiger leur
dissertation ou pour tricher aux examens
le corps enseignant s'inquiète car chat
GPT est également capable de donner des
cours mais au lieu de le craindre
l'équipe pédagogique du cours griffon à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux a décidé de le
tester pour en parler avec nous Xavier
du Bellay le fondateur du cours griffon
alors certaines écoles comme Sciences Po
ont décidé de l'interdire à leurs élèves
vous vous avez décidé de vous en servir
pourquoi alors on a décidé de le tester
pas forcément de nous en servir encore
que
effectivement Sciences Po interdit à ses
élèves de s'en servir je sais pas du
tout comment ils vont gérer le fait de
faire appliquer cette interdiction mais
vous ça s'arrête pas là vous avez l'État
de New York qui a décidé pour toute la
zone d'interdire cgbt dans les dans les
alors nous on s'y intéressé parce qu'en
fait depuis le début depuis la fondation
du corps griffon en 2013
on s'intéresse systématiquement chaque
année aux nouveautés scientifiques
notamment en neurosciences comment
fonctionne le cerveau des enfants et aux
nouvelles
technologiques tout ce qui est numérique
évidemment le logiciel informatique pour
intégrer tout ça au sein d'un pédagogie
de notre pédagogie et
de proposer toujours le meilleur à nos
élèves donc le coryphon c'est la fin non
seulement très classique et très moderne
et donc là vous avez décidé de chat GPT
comment ça s'est passé concrètement
comment vous avez mis en place
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le 4
ans déjà que je m'y intéresse et dès que
j'ai eu vend d'une intelligence
artificielle grand public qui allait
être accessible à tous les gens de la
planète et en particulier aux élèves on
a créé un compte soin de novembre et on
était dans les premiers et on s'est jeté
dessus pour voir un peu comment ça
fonctionnait et en fait très rapidement
on a été déçu très rapidement on a été
déçu on a pris deux angles on s'est dit
on se la place de la du point de vue
d'un élève et puis du point de vue du
professeur alors du point de vue d'un
élève on s'est mis dans l'impôt d'un
élève de 10-11 ans et on s'est dit
tchat j'ai pété explique-moi la règle de
l'accord du participe passé qui a un
point clé de du français qui est
toujours une difficulté récurrente chez
les enfants en fin de primaire au
collège au lycée j'ai beaucoup d'adultes
aussi
et on s'est rendu compte que les
informations qu'il donnait étaient
partiels
voir fausse et par exemple il
mentionnait jamais
le cas où le COD est placé avant le
verbe évidemment on doit accorder
et du coup c'était quand même assez
pauvre c'était quand même assez pauvre
et ça devenait faux et du coup en
réfléchissant on s'est dit en fait
cette nouveauté technologie très
puissante quand même quand on sait bien
s'en servir ça va accroître les
inégalités du côté des élèves parce que
les élèves qui vont vraiment en tirer
profit sont ceux qui auront des bases
solides en maths en français une
certaine culture générale et qui vont
être capables d'utiliser l'outil de le
faire parler de le configurer le
paramétrer le passer en mode Expert s'il
y a des façons de rendre encore plus
performant
et puis de faire le tri entre les
réponses et de voir ce qui est approprié
ce qui est défaillance ce qui doit être
pris en compte mais aménagé
et évidemment un élève un peu faible qui
a pas les bases qui est pas le recul qui
est pas les éléments les connaissances
nécessaires elle va être perdue va
prendre pour argent comptant ce que le
logiciel va lui donner va faire copier
coller médecin dans sa copie et avoir
une autre moyenne mais il aura pas ni
fait le travail lui-même ni appris à
réfléchir en fait donc c'est ça au
niveau des élèves c'est ça le principal
danger
la limite aussi en fonction de la
transmission du savoir j'imagine que
certains élèves les petits ont besoin
d'une personne enfin d'un humain pour
transmettre pour avoir la transmission
du savoir ou même certaines formes
d'intelligence en fait ou de mémoire
nécessite la parole absolument c'est le
deuxième point c'est vis-à-vis du
professeur la question c'est est-ce que
ça va remplacer le professeur et on va
reprendre vos éléments
parce que beaucoup de professeurs ont vu
ça comme une menace mais ça attaque
aussi tous les métiers intellectuels en
fait les journalistes les avocats
tout ce qui avait été quelque part
préservé par la révolution industrielle
va quelque part souffrir il va y avoir
une évolution de ces métiers et donc les
professeurs se sentent menacés et
peut-être à juste titre je sais pas
mais si on revient à la racine du métier
professeur enseigné c'est d'abord un art
c'est pas une simplement une technique
donc c'est un art parce qu'il faut
maîtriser
et tirer profit de la tradition
pédagogique française on a la chance
d'avoir inconnu en France la meilleure
école du monde que tout le monde nous
enviait et tout ça reposer sur des
proies bien conçus et des méthodes
efficaces qui se sont un peu perdus donc
au griffons on prend par exemple les
manuels du grip édition qui sont des
manuels qui reprennent le meilleur de
l'instruction française on les prend en
primaire notamment comme base de
programme et puis après on les enrichit
avec d'autres éléments
c'est un art également parce qu'il faut
connaître ses élèves le professeur il
doit connaître les élèves quasiment
individuellement
connaître leur passé leur passé scolaire
leur force leur faiblesse et à la limite
tu vas connaître leur caractère parce
qu'on enseigne pas de la même façon à
tout le monde suivant les tempéraments
et il doit également concevoir des cours
qui parlent à toutes les formes
d'intelligence que vous mentionnez donc
les auditifs les visuels et
kinesthésiques
kinesthésique c'est un élève qui a
besoin de bouger pour apprendre ou
d'écrire pour apprendre par exemple
et ça tu as des BT au point où on en est
c'est quand même assez pauvre et en fait
si on prend un peu de hauteur tout ce
qui manque à ces systèmes informatiques
c'est une incarnation en fait le
problème de chat GPT c'est que c'est pas
un humain il a pas il a pas de corps non
mais c'est même pas un robot humanoïde
même demain si c'est un humanoïde il se
serait pas un humain parce que le
cerveau humain ça s'est démontré en
audience on a la chance d'être pas loin
de NeuroSpin au CEA de Saclay qui a un
centre très pointu sur le
la compréhension des du fonctionnement
des enfants en particulier sur notamment
sur les neurones des circuits neuronaux
qui sont impliqués la lecture
et bien on sait bien qu'un cerveau
humain il comprend quand il regarde
quelqu'un quand il écoute la voix de
quelqu'un et il se passe un phénomène de
neurones si
quelqu'un a expliqué quelque chose ou
ressent quelque chose son interlocuteur
sans rien faire va modéliser mentalement
tout ce qui est en train de dire tout ce
qu'il est en train de ressentir et du
coup c'est à la limite de tous ces
outils qui sont qui sont qui ne sont que
des outils techniques et pas
il y a pas d'épaisseur humaine et on
peut on pourrait dériver sur dans
l'apprentissage il y a un élément
important qui est la charge émotionnelle
plus on ressent de choses
de couleur de sentiments quand on
apprend quelque chose plus on va le
réciter profondément et être capable de
les restituer
c'est une technique de mémorisation
d'ailleurs pour des champion du monde de
mémoire ils utilisent notamment ces
techniques là mais on le fait
naturellement
et ça c'est absent de ces systèmes
informatiques
du plateau vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
de de tester tchat GPT
j'ai jamais testé j'ai pas encore testé
pas encore personnellement pas non plus
mais c'est vrai que ça donne envie de
tester pour voir un petit peu les
limites et ce que c'est capable de faire
aussi Thierry Michel dans l'exercice
mais je suis une mise en scène et ça
peut être un outil intéressant dans les
mairies oui je pense qu'il peut demain
c'est l'intelligence artificielle qui
demeure rendent des services dans le
fonctionnement des mairies après il faut
qu'on travaille au cas par cas c'est des
outils qui peut être intéressant sur des
gestion de finances sur des gestion de
patrimoine après lorsqu'on est sur de la
gestion de services au public
fonctionnement des crèches en ce moment
des écoles de la restauration scolaire
pour l'utilité viendra peut-être un jour
mais l'outil est encore récent je crois
que vous l'avez bien dit il y a encore
beaucoup à voir
et bien merci en tout cas Xavier du
Bellay d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je le rappelle vous êtes le fondateur du
cours gryffond à Voisins le bretonneux
la semaine dernière l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
organisé une conférence sur les droits
des femmes au total trois femmes ont pu
apporter leur expérience professionnelle
devant les étudiants après l'interview
d'une gynécologue et d'une directrice de
théâtre on écoute aujourd'hui Marjorie
Desjardins auteur réalisatrice et
photographe elle a répondu aux questions
de Céline Charles
[Musique]
Marjorie Desjardins je suis réalisatrice
de documentaire photographe et aussi
chef opératrice mon premier documentaire
s'appelle femme sans filigran c'est avec
ma grand-mère et Benoît de Groult et en
fait c'est un portrait croisé entre les
deux femmes
ma grand-mère ayant plutôt subi sa vie
de femmes et Benoît de Gould est en
devenu féministe et reconnu plutôt
verset 40 ans et ont pris les armes des
mots pour pour témoigner
je suis venue aujourd'hui pour présenter
des extraits de mes films qui traitent
du rapport des femmes à leur corps et de
l'évolution des femmes dans la société
et nous sommes semblait très important
dans un endroit tel qu'une faculté de
droits de transmettre ce que j'ai pu
apprendre sur pas mal d'années ou dans
mes rencontres et faire du documentaire
c'est pouvoir s'asseoir à la table du
diable c'est à dire aborder tous les
sujets et puis faire un petit peu bouger
les curseurs de ce qu'ils peuvent ou
aura été
mais on dire mes illusions
mes prérequis mon éducation bousculer
mon ethnocentrisme
[Musique]
en tant que femme je suis libre et je ne
suis en grandissant vers la vingtaine où
je me suis dit mais en fait j'ai des
j'ai des limites parce que je suis fan
c'est quoi c'est connerie et c'est en
discutant avec ma grand-mère de tout ce
qu'elle avait vu vivre que je me suis
dit attends là il faut regarder sur
certaines choses et en fait c'était les
autres qui me rappelaient que j'étais
femme comme si être femme
m'empêchait ce qui était quelque chose
pour moi de totalement inconcevable
puisque je pouvais partir avec mon sac à
dos et ma caméra faire des documentaires
un peu partout dans le monde comme le
disait Benoît de Goult et que dit à la
fin de mon film c'est que c'est aux
hommes de faire un effort maintenant si
on veut une égalité dans les droits on
les a mais on va dire le salaire etc
c'est à eux de faire des efforts et de
rétrocéder du terrain c'est difficile
[Musique]
et si vous avez manqué les deux
premières interviews vous pouvez les
retrouver dès à présent sur notre chaîne
YouTube allez on ouvre à présent une
page loisirs
[Musique]
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
Laurent gara bonsoir alors vous êtes le
gérant de la librairie le pavé du canal
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec vous dans
quelques instants on va parler de la
fête de la librairie indépendante mais
avant on va parler un petit peu de sport
Zumba badminton athlétisme ou encore
Street workout de nombreuses activités
sportives sont disponibles en libre
accès dans la commune d'Élancourt
jusqu'au mois de juin c'est dans le
cadre du Printemps du sport pour en
parler avec nous Thierry Michel le
premier adjoint Homère à Élancourt alors
en début d'émission vous nous parlez un
petit peu des objectifs de du Printemps
du sport notamment encouragé l'activité
physique mais aussi faire découvrir aux
habitants les associations sportives et
les infrastructures sportives oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui le sport il est
pratiqué de trois manières en matière
scolaire on voit effectivement qu'on a
accompagnement et nous mettons à
disposition les équipements que détient
la commune et on fait même des
accompagnements avec le savoir nager le
rouler on a acheté des vélos et les
enfants apprennent à rouler dans l'école
donc ça c'est une première manière de
faire du sport il y a la manière par le
tissu associatif qu'on connaît tous on
vient s'inscrire dans une association
sur un sport qu'on a envie de faire on
vient chercher aussi de la compétition
et puis de plus en plus se développe le
sport loisirs le sport plaisir qui s'est
peut-être encore plus développé avec la
crise sanitaire donc aujourd'hui on a
effectivement une profession qui dit je
veux faire du sport mais le tissu
associatif ne peut pas toujours répondre
à mes attentes notamment en matière
d'horaire donc c'est mieux que je puisse
faire deux activités et c'est ça qu'on a
voulu faire effectivement avec le
printemps du sport c'est de montrer tous
les équipements de faire aussi découvrir
nos associations parce qu'elles sont pas
toujours connues et de venir tester les
sports c'est ce qu'on fait dans le cadre
de l'association de la démo des
associations qui est un temps fort ou
beaucoup d'associations présentent leurs
activités alors justement quelles sont
les sports qui seront à tester ou à
découvrir l'espoir collectif l'histoire
individuel ça passe par tout ce qui
tourne autour des arts martiaux c'est le
rugby le football le foot américain le
volley-ball le basketball enfin bon j'en
oublie certainement mais j'espère que
les présidents de clubs n'en voudront
pas et il y aura aussi une zone de
street workout est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce que c'est oui alors ça
c'est des nouveautés c'est de la
pratique du sport dans son quartier
aujourd'hui toujours dans ce cas du
sport un peu en matière libres on a
développé deux structures une dans le
quartier de la caisse Saint-Pierre et
une qui est en cours de construction
dans le quartier des Petits Prés c'est
effectivement je fais du sport je fais
mon footing mais je veux aller sur des
équipements disponibles voilà on a une
aire qui est disponible avec même
capacité par des écrans de venir
chercher du programme et du contenu pour
dire que les exercices je vais faire
bénévolat du tissu associatif qui
viennent présenter en silence sport
est-ce que c'est un moyen aussi pour la
commune de créer plus de sociabilité ça
va faire se rencontrer les gens c'est un
bon moyen de faire des rencontres
je crois que le tissu associatif on est
le meilleur exemple c'est le Christ
sanitaire bon qui s'est achevé enfin
parlons pas trop rapidement à montrer
toutes les faiblesses et physiquement de
d'organisation et on en a tous exprimé
ce besoin d'être dehors et encore une
fois le tissu associatif répond en
grande majeure partie mais j'ai
aujourd'hui on trouve chez des personnes
une autre volonté de faire du sport
tardivement on voit des gens qui courent
très très tôt le matin on va essayer
effectivement de pouvoir les accompagner
alors en tant que premier management à
Élancourt est-ce que vous avez déjà
testé l'aire de street workout est-ce
que vous pratiquez un sport à Élancourt
alors moi je fais du sport effectivement
je fais beaucoup de marche à pied j'ai
pas encore eu l'occasion je vais l'avoir
parce que lorsque la nouvelle ère de
dans le quartier des petits pressera
livré je me suis effectivement dans une
tenue adaptée
avec les jeunes parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans ces deux projets ce
sont des jeunes des quartiers qui nous
ont demandé ces projets qui les ont bâti
donc ça a été co-construit avec la
population du quartier et qui nous ont
dit ben voilà et qu'on conçu eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas nous qui
avons dit bah voilà on va mettre tel
était à la Grèce qui sont venus avec un
plan voilà comment on voit les choses
voilà comment on veut faire et l'idée
c'était d'y attention c'est pas une aire
que pour les jeunes c'est une aire
intergénérationnel il faut que tout le
monde puisse venir s'exprimer peuvent
faire du sport les femmes comme les
hommes autour du plateau vous avez déjà
utilisé des structures sportives à
l'extérieur ça vous arrivez ou pas avec
mes enfants
dans nos villes il y a justement cette
possibilité que nous a offert donc bien
sûr c'est vrai qu'on pense qu'on fait
souvent des parcours de santé en forêt
moi je pense à ça oui j'ai l'impression
qu'il y en a de plus en plus dans les
villes
ça se développe et nous avons proposé
l'année dernière un budget participatif
et dans le cadre de ce budget
participatif on a des rencontres qui a
proposé un parcours santé et nous étions
encore cet après-midi avec lui en train
de voir l'endroit comment le on
l'organise comment il voit les choses et
c'est ça qui est intéressant et bien
merci beaucoup Michel d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je le rappelle vous êtes
le premier adjoint au maire pour la
commune d'Élancourt vous restez avec
nous on va parler d'humour à présent
puisque l'humoriste François Guédon sera
à la royale Factory 2 Versailles ce soir
ainsi que le vendredi 14 avril et le
samedi 15 avril il présentera son
spectacle le procès Guédon et il est
avec nous à distance pour en parler
François Guédon bonsoir
bonsoir à tous et bonsoir à toutes alors
le procès Guédon en quelques mots c'est
votre propre procès à vous vous êtes
accusé par le public de ne plus rien
respecter la religion les philosophes et
vous vous défendez vous-même
exactement
on est dans une société où tout devient
un petit peu le procès ou les réseaux
sociaux sont aussi dans une mesure un
grand un grand procès donc je m'étais
dit que cette formule et cette forme en
termes de mise en scène était
intéressante
il y a l'autodérision il y a le comique
de situation de gestes vous votre point
fort c'est plutôt les mots vous utilisez
les mots pour faire rire les gens
oui oui enfin je pense qu'on utilise
tous les mots après moi c'est vrai que
j'ai de par ma formation j'ai fait une
prépa lettre j'aime beaucoup les mots et
puis j'aime bien tourner en dérision
aussi le côté gardien du temple de la
Littérature de ces gens qui me disent on
ne peut pas toucher à racine on ne peut
pas toucher à Molière et ben si tout
change
oui d'ailleurs durant ce procès vous
vous défendez en disant que vous êtes le
seul qui puisse réconcilier Nabilla avec
racine
oui oui après je pense que je suis le
seul aussi à vouloir peut-être cette
réconciliation mais c'est l'occasion
d'un sketch ou j'imagine et si racine
avait écrit Les Anges de la téléréalité
qu'est-ce que ça aurait pu donner et
c'est un sketch où il y a Jean Karine
timberley et Kevin qui parle en
alexandrin mais avec des mots
d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des nouveaux
mots dans la langue française que c'est
que c'est un problème moi je suis en
défenseur d'Aya Nakamura dans le texte
et sur la piste de vente alors quel
message vous souhaitez faire passer
durant votre spectacle
bah je pense enfin disons que c'est mon
avis je prétends pas avoir raison je
pense qu'on peut rire de tout je pense
qu'on doit rire de tout et que il faut
savoir voilà ne rien s'interdire dans le
choix des sujets ou dans la manière de
les utiliser et c'est pour ça que je
mets notamment la littérature et la
télé-réalité c'est dire on a des
nouvelles formes de culture il faut s'en
emparer et il faut il faut les parodies
ils font faire des pastilles il faut il
faut s'amuser avec tout ça vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
rire de tout en tout cas qu'il faut
faire extrêmement attention à tout ce
qu'on dit pour pas attirer de
commentaires négatifs
du pub je pense que c'est une très bonne
chose qu'on ne puisse plus faire les
sketchs de Michel Leeb ou il dit que les
noirs ont des grosses narines ça je
pense que c'est une vraie avancé mais
oui c'est c'est important de se poser
des questions sur le fait de pas
offenser les gens mais il faut pas que
cette volonté de ne pas offenser
Vienne nuire à la capacité de l'humour
justement à déranger parce que l'humour
ça doit toujours rester quelque chose de
grand son
alors Gabriel une journaliste un plateau
aussi une question pour vous oui bonsoir
est-ce que vous vous êtes servis
justement de critique que vous avez
vous-même reçu pour pour ce spectacle
je me suis pas vraiment servi de
critique mais
quand j'ai et je ne citerai pas son nom
mais une responsable de médiathèque qui
me dit qu'on a pas le droit de toucher à
racine je me dis que j'ai exactement
raison de tout ça racine parce que c'est
ces personnes là aussi que j'ai un petit
peu envie de déranger et c'est et c'est
ce type de littérature que j'ai envie de
dépoussiérer mais pour le pour le bien
commun
alors est-ce que durant votre spectacle
vous interagissez beaucoup avec le
public
alors moi je suis plutôt de l'école du
Théâtre et de l'école du sketch mais il
y a notamment un cours de philosophie
sur les rappeurs ou le public sont mes
élèves donc où j'interagis avec eux sur
des notions comme
l'existentialisme ou le bouddhisme
et donc ce soir on a aussi avec
ah oui on n'a pas entendu la fin ce soir
on est aussi avec le gérant d'une
librairie et donc je crois qu'il a aussi
une question pour vous juste sur le
printemps des potes il y a Booba qui a
fait un recueil de poésie savoir si ça
avait été un support aussi pour vous
parce que c'est vraiment du Booba dans
le texte et voilà c'est ça a été c'est
un bon un bon carton en librairie
indépendante en tout cas ça fonctionne
bien
c'est moi je pense c'est en plus c'est
une des phrases du sketch que le rap est
une nouvelle forme de poésie non je
plaise je ne sais pas moi pinkle par
exemple et je vais un petit peu plus
loin dans ce cash en disant que il y a
une forme de il y a une forme de
philosophie dans le rapport je fais un
rapprochement par exemple entre le
stoïcisme et Jul que je trouve que je
trouve pertinente mais c'est très bien
de toute façon que les gens lisent que
les gens écoutent et si ça doit passer
par le rap et bien passons par le rap
il y a des grosses passerelles
effectivement entre la poésie et la
culture et le rap donc et je pense que
le rap aussi c'est pour faire attirer
des un public plus jeune
ou pas forcément
dans ce type de sketch là j'apprends ce
qui est l'existentialisme au moins de 25
et je fais découvrir Booba au prix de 25
alors là on voit vous êtes dans une
salle sombre vous êtes à la Royal
Factory de Versailles vous êtes en train
de répéter
vous êtes actuellement en direct des
loges de la Royal Factory à Versailles
ou François gallon se produira ce soir
demain et après demain soir ou après
l'assurance on vient de finir les
réglages et le spectacle commence ici 2
heures 20h30 il reste des places encore
ou pas il reste encore pour pour ce soir
un petit peu moins pour vendredi à
samedi mais n'hésitez pas
et bien merci François Guédon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions si vous êtes
intéressé le spectacle le procès Guédon
se tiendra le 14 et le 15 avril ou dès
ce soir à la Royal Factory de Versailles
début du show à 20h30 un autre
rendez-vous est à ne pas manquer ce
week-end ça se passe à Houilles le
spectacle radio situs Altus Fortus et
présenté à la graine trie le concept
sous la forme d'une émission de radio
Merlot vous propose de vous plonger dans
le monde du sport ils nous ont dit plus
au micro de Julien Leroy
[Musique]
l'historique du spectacle c'est une
belle histoire parce que ça a commencé
dans une école où j'ai écrit des
chansons avec des enfants dans une école
de Thiais l'école avec laquelle je
travaille régulièrement et on avait
envie de faire quelque chose sur pour
préparer 2024 avec les enfants donner du
sens à ce qu'ils allaient entendre
pendant des années sur le sport le
résultat ça a donné un spectacle qu'on a
donné nos quartiers pour les parents etc
c'était tellement bien que
j'ai envoyé les chansons à l'éditeur qui
fait des livres discours enfants et qu'à
mordu tout de suite donc c'est devenu un
livre disque c'est la suite de ce livre
disque Virginie de comète la boîte qui
nous fait tourner qui m'a dit mais ça
faut faire un spectacle aussi et puis on
en discutant on s'est dit que ça
pourrait être bien d'intégrer des
acrobates
[Musique]
c'est trop cool c'est les vacances
à la fois c'est vraiment des chansons et
puis en même temps c'est vraiment du
cirque c'est vraiment du clown donc on a
on a dû chercher moi j'avais jamais
travaillé avec des circassiens des
circassiens n'avaient en gros j'ai envie
de travailler avec des musiciens donc
fallait qu'on se règle et puis une fois
qu'on a trouvé en été hyper content du
résultat il y a un truc autour du cirque
truc un peu clown un peu le cirque en
fait ça mélange bien tout ça et donc on
s'amuse beaucoup c'est enfin c'était
vraiment
une belle rencontre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis pas très fan dans l'âme donc je
connais pas forcément les personnages
mais par exemple Usain Bolt c'est
quelqu'un de fort pour moi moi j'aime le
reggae je connais la Jamaïque je connais
plein de fois
et lui représente quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire quoi une petite île de
rien du tout elle qui arrive à fabriquer
des coureurs incroyables on n'a pas
toujours pas compris que pourquoi il y a
un truc avec la aussi la l'humeur que ce
mec là dégage et quelque chose de hyper
positif d'hyper drôle passe c'est pas au
sérieux il y a des exemples de
détermination de passion de force
mentale qui sont voilà que on avait
envie de parler sur toute ça en fait les
gens avec un cerveau
et nous avons été rejoints plateau par
un autre journaliste de la rédaction de
TV 78 Grégory canalet bonsoir bonsoir
alors comme d'habitude maintenant le
jeudi vous nous présenter le quiz alors
sur quoi est-ce que vous allez nous
challenger ce soir dans les étoiles
c'est un voyage spatial que je vais vous
proposer puisque demain décolle
normalement une mission spatiale avec à
son bord land spyer set seven c'est le
Nano satellite qui a été développé par
le l'Atmos à Guyancourt et donc je vais
vous challenger autour de l'univers de
l'espace les liens entre l'espace et les
Yvelines il y en a ils sont nombreux un
sujet un peu pointu on essayera de
répondre à vos questions plus ou moins
difficiles si difficile il y aura de
pour tous les niveaux mais avant on va
parler de la fête de la librairie
indépendante Laurent Garin je me tourne
vers vous vous êtes le gérant de la
librairie le pavé du canal situé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il s'agit de la
25e édition de la Fête de la librairie
indépendante elle aura lieu tout ce
samedi alors quel est le but de cette
journée de montrer l'importance des
librairies
comme acteur culturel et donc cette fête
vient d'Espagne en fait la saint Jordy
habituellement c'est le 23 avril cette
année il y a le salon du il y a le
festival du Salon du livre de Paris donc
ils ont avancé la date mais voilà donc
c'est pour remettre la librairie
indépendante devant et pour montrer tout
l'attrait qui peut y avoir à aller en
librairie indépendante et alors
qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour à cette
journée spéciale pour nous en fait on va
délivrer des jolies fascicules qui ont
été éditées par les éditions gallima
donc en fait oui c'est ça c'est 25
double page où la thématique reste
autour des oiseaux voilà donc il y a
d'accord donc c'est Michael caillou qui
a illustré les 25 textes donc toutes les
textes donc il y a 25 autres prises 25
auteurs tout autour des oiseaux donc là
c'était le foot basson parce que la mer
et que j'aime bien ça et donc on va
donner ça à nos clients voilà on va leur
offrir cet ouvrage là et nous en plus on
va recevoir un scénariste de manga
français ce qui est quand même assez
rare aux éditions Cana donc on va le
recevoir la libération on va discuter un
peu avec lui si on s'agit de sur sa vie
de scénariste comment il crée comment
vis-à-vis du Japon ça fonctionne aussi
parce que les mangas sont très régis par
le Japon enfin c'est très compliqué de
sortir du spectre du spectre japonais
donc là voilà la France aussi qui est
une grande scène internationale du manga
on va là on va discuter avec cette
hauteur là face scénariste là prend de
plus en plus de place
en plus dans notre librairie nous avec
l'espace qu'on a ouvert je peux pas dire
l'inverse on a ouvert sur maintenant on
a 12000 volumes de manga et c'est il y a
un fort après sur tout style en plus
éditorial c'est ça qui est vraiment
super intéressant c'est avant c'était
vraiment très cantonné sur la jeunesse
maintenant on ouvre à plein de choses à
de l'histoire à énormément de choses à
des récits de vie également et donc oui
le manga est très porteur et le soir
juste pour finir et le soir on va faire
du hip-hop donc voilà c'est pour montrer
qu'une librairie indépendante ce n'est
pas qu'un commerce en fait dans une
ville c'est aussi un acteur culturel
donc on est à la croisée de couteau
je suis très ami avec une troupe de
voisins qui élite danse donc je les
invite on va pousser un peu les
bibliothèques les tapes plein de livres
voilà ça va être une scène et ça va être
une vraie salle de danse
c'est ça justement qui fait la force des
librairies indépendantes aujourd'hui
face aux plus grandes librairies aux
Chênes c'est ces échanges cette ces
liens le lien en fait ça c'est l'accueil
c'est le fait que ce soit des personnels
formés et professionnels qui se
connaissent les ouvrages et qu'on fasse
pas qu'un commerce en fait c'est qu'on
est aussi acteur culturel à proprement
parler vous avez un vrai rôle social
c'est aussi d'amener la culture aux gens
qui viennent et d'amener la lecture
également parce qu'on fait aussi partie
de l'opération qui s'appelle jeunes en
librairie on accueille des collèges ou
des lycées dans la librairie donc la
classe se déplace une fois en librairie
pour qu'on leur explique la chaîne du
livre et une seconde fois où il y a un
auteur ou une autrice qui viennent et
qui parle de leur métier donc oui c'est
aussi ça des librairies indépendantes et
donc on est loin du cliché le jeune ne
lit pas on est très loin
complètement et en plus c'est ça qui est
intéressant pour nous c'est qu'on
apprend plein plein de choses quoi il y
a une vraie interaction qui se crée avec
également
pas sculpture qui s'est mis en place
donc ça fait venir d'autres personnes
dans la librairie ça ouvre vraiment les
portes à plein de monde et alors à
partir d'octobre commander un livre sur
Internet coûtera plus cher les frais de
livraison vont passer à 3 euros à la
place de quelques centimes d'euros c'est
une bonne nouvelle selon vous ça peut
vous aider c'est une première bonne
nouvelle en fait ce que nous livrer un
indépendant on demandait en fait que la
gratuité la presque gratuite des frais
de port soit complètement arrêté donc là
en fait c'est 3 € jusqu'à un panier de
35 euros dès qu'il y a un livre en fait
on peut mixer du livre et un hors-livre
donc jusqu'à 35 euros c'est 3 euros au 2
au-delà des 35 euros ça repasse à 1
centime voilà donc on va dire qu'à
moitié du chemin pour le librairie
indépendant est fait mais en tout cas
c'est une très très bonne chose ouais
pour la librairie indépendante pour
replacer un peu à niveau les
concurrences qui peuvent exister entre
les commerces
hors sol et les commerces justement la
concurrence est rude avec les
plateformes en ligne enfin vous arrivez
à vous en sortir
c'est complètement différent on
fonctionne pas du tout sur la même
créneau quoi nous on est vraiment là
pour faire des liens pour gérer de
l'humain en fait et avoir des
discussions on n'est pas des plateformes
logistiques on voilà c'est complètement
différent donc on a chacun notre raison
d'être vous sentez de la vous ressentez
de la part de vos clients la volonté de
vous soutenir en allant plutôt en
librairie que de commander sur internet
avec le confinement en fait sur tout là
on a senti que il y avait un fort regain
en fait de popularité de soutien en fait
des gens vis-à-vis des commerces locaux
une prise de cons il y a une vraie prise
de conscience et en plus il y avait du
temps de cerveau disponible donc les
gens se sont mis à lire donc la
conjoncture des deux a fait que la
librairie indépendance est vraiment bien
portée à la sortie du confinement c'est
une question sur ça justement il y a eu
un basculement vous aviez mis en place
des drives le drive à la librairie du
canal du pavé du canal il y a eu une
bascule oui avec le confinement c'était
ma question nous on a fonctionné à plein
pendant le drive effectivement oui oui
et on arrive encore à faire des conseils
par mail par téléphone enfin voilà donc
il y avait encore ce petit lien qu'on
avait réussi à maintenir mais oui ça a
bien fonctionné enfin ça a fonctionné
pendant le confinement et après dès
qu'on est passé commercial là on a
repris une activité qui était à peu près
normale et là on a repris ouais on a
notre place dans la dans la ville et
bien merci beaucoup Laurent Garin
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
les Yvelines cinq autres librairies
célèbre la fête de la librairie
indépendante ce samedi 15 avril là les
deux feuilles à saint-germain-en-lay les
petits mots à Chatou des gens qui
nuisent à Sartrouville les chemins du
livre à maison Lafitte et le pavé dans
la mare à Élancourt
c'est un petit village à librairie
française donc oui c'est des amis
c'est l'heure à présent de passer à nos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines
Gabriel à l'approche du week-end vous
nous avez préparé vos meilleurs plans et
on commence ce soir avec une nouvelle
chasse aux oeufs pour ceux qui
voudraient encore profiter de la fête et
des chocolats il reste des événements
dans les Yvelines le département des
Yvelines et le musée départemental
Maurice Denis à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
vous invite pour une grande chasse aux
œufs c'est ce samedi Mathilde au travers
du parc et Desjardins en famille ou
entre amis vous pourrez récupérer les
œufs déposés tardivement par les cloches
un événement qui peut être aussi
l'occasion de découvrir le musée où et
notamment exposé des collections
originales consacrées au peintre
symboliste et post impressionniste une
bonne façon d'allier gourmandise et
culture et on continue justement de
parler de culture puisque ce week-end
réel sur scène propose une plongée dans
la culture chinoise avec un événement à
ne pas manquer Gabriel oui je vous en
parlais en début d'émission
l'association le dragon bleu accueille
un moine Shaolin alors d'après la
tradition la cinquième siècle que les
moines du temple Shaolin aurait été
formé au Kung Fu Shaolin par un moine
venu d'Inde alors l'objectif à l'époque
les aider à se défendre des ennemis
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'un art à part
entière dédié à la défense et non à
l'attaque qui nécessite beaucoup de
préparation avant de pouvoir être
ordonné officiellement alors au
programme du weekend des sessions de
tai-chi de kikong et de kung fu vous
pouvez y participer en achetant dès
maintenant vos places mais vous pouvez
aussi profiter du spectacle complètement
gratuitement au-delà de la martiale
c'est tout un état d'esprit bouddhiste
philosophique et même d'éducation qui
est venu transmettre le moi un bel
événement en perspective on va parler
maintenant d'environnement avec la fête
de la transition écologique qui s'invite
à Guyancourt oui au programme de
nombreuses activités et des ateliers
dédiés à la sensibilisation et à
l'environnement alors parmi eux la
création de décoration de jardin avec
des matériaux recyclés en plastique des
rencontres avec des professionnels pour
apprendre les principes du le prix du
recyclage mais aussi du réemploi et de
la réparation d'autres thématiques sont
également au programme de la journée
comme l'alimentation qui peut aussi se
révéler plus durable un rendez-vous qui
se veut à la fois ludique et instructif
pour développer au quotidien ces
éco-gestes et parmi les éco-gestes à
adopter et à développer justement le
vélo comme moyen de transport une
après-midi lui est consacrée à Plaisir
oui pour les cyclistes avertis ou les
débutants rendez-vous samedi au château
de plaisir pour rencontrer les services
de la ville et les bénévoles de
l'association plaisir en transition
alors le but de cette de cette journée
développer l'utilisation du vélo dans la
ville un événement qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre des actions de la ville en faveur
d'une politique plus responsable et de
développement durable et enfin on
termine vos idées de sortie Gabriel avec
une inauguration qui va peut-être vous
donner envie de vous remettre au sport
si ce n'est pas déjà fait avec le
printemps du sport à Elancourt Lucie
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours vous
vient l'envie de vous mettre au sport
samedi à l'inauguration du club le
village à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux réouvert le
premier mars après des travaux de
modernisation le club de sport propose
samedi des visites commentées des
différentes espaces de pratiques alors
vous avez du fitness du squash du
badminton du tennis ou encore du foot
indoor qui sont proposés un
établissement
modernisé avec une offre de sport très
diversifiée et d'ailleurs certains de
nos collègues ont déjà pu tester le
squash et n'est-ce pas Grégory
quel collègue je suis une défaite de la
part de ce collègue mais en tout cas on
a pu tester les cours de squash qui sont
de très bonne qualité vous validez on
valide on valide alors comme d'habitude
petit tour de plateau qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse le plus parmi toutes ces idées
de sortie
la transition écologique
on poursuit avec le quiz alors Grégory
canalet si j'ai bien suivi ce soir vous
nous emmener dans l'espace on vous
emmène je vous emmène voilà je parle de
moi la troisième personne ça y est c'est
la télé qui joue sur moi je vous parle
d'espace ou des liens de l'espace et des
Yvelines justement parce qu'ils sont au
nombreux ces liens entre l'espace et les
Yvelines on rappelle que demain
normalement parce que plusieurs reports
devraient décoller une mission au bord
au bord duquel se trouvera de laquelle
se trouvera pardon hand spyer sat seven
c'est le Nano satellite qui a été
développé par l'UVSQ et ce que vous êtes
prêt Laurent peut jouer également avec
nous derrière votre écran vous pouvez
bien sûr jouer aussi avec nous est-ce
qu'on fait des des équipes on fait
chacun pour soi ce que vous êtes trois
on fait un deux contre un Mathilde
on fait un deux contre un donc Tim
Gabriel Laurent contre team Mathilde qui
est donc toute seule première question
on peut se former justement sur les
métiers de l'espace dans les Yvelines et
plus précisément sur les un métier
d'ingénieur spatial dans ce domaine il y
a une école qui justement propose une
formation dans le domaine du spatial
quel est son nom à cette école
donc une filière spatiale dans une école
yvelinoise je vous demande le nom de
l'école yvinoise qui propose cette
filière spatiale
c'est une école donc qui n'est pas
regroupée dans une université qui ne
fait pas partie d'une université
ça vous dit rien à 50 ans en Yvelines à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux très précisément
j'ai pas envie de dire de bêtises mais
je suis sûre que je connais
pas de réponse pour cette première
question il s'agit de l'ESTACA l'école
d'ingénieur spécialisée dans les métiers
de la mobilité l'un des deux campus
français situé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
on peut se former dans les filières de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile et du
ferroviaire et donc du spatial la
filière spatiale permet de pouvoir
intervenir ensuite dans la construction
de lanceur d'engins spatiaux et de
propulseurs mais aussi et de participer
au lancement et à l'exploitation des
satellites 00 entre la team Gabriel
Laurent contre eux Mathilde le l'Atmos
dont je vous parlais il y a un instant
un laboratoire atmosphère observation
spatiale basée donc à Guyancourt en
voyant en orbite l'UVSQ sat A un anneau
satellite ce sera bientôt le cas pour
l'âne spire sat seven normalement demain
vendredi le laboratoire est donc situé à
Guyancourt et à travailler aussi sur
d'autres programmes la mission spatiale
Rosetta notamment nous sommes en 2014
après 10 ans de voyage la sonde s'est
mise en orbite autour de la comète
tchouri et il y a envoyé son robot
l'atterrissage a été retransmée en
direct au l'Atmos c'était le 12 novembre
2014 est-ce que vous souvenez du nom du
robot de cette mission Rosetta quel nom
portait le robot de la mission Rosetta
à Star Wars non rien du tout Rosetta ça
vous évoque rien bon j'ai prévu vraiment
des des questions difficiles ce soir il
s'agit de filae ça ne vous dit rien non
malheureusement bon je vais revoir les
questions avec un peu plus de facilité
la prochaine fois donc filae robot
laboratoire de la mission Rosetta le
l'Atmos a développé 7 des 21 instruments
de filae c'était la première fois dans
l'histoire qu'un robot se posait
directement sur une comète le tout à 7,9
milliards de kilomètres de la Terre
filet à collecter les données les
transmetteurs Rosetta qui était en
orbite autour de cette comète qui est
elle-même Rosetta renvoyait les données
à notre terre on a pris deux choses
essentielles sur l'existence notre
propre existence grâce à cette mission
déjà première chose le présente sur
cette comète n'a rien à voir avec l'eau
qui est présente sur terre donc cette
cette comète donc j'ai oublié le nom n'a
pas Touri voilà n'a pas participé
directement à l'apport de l'eau sur
Terre deuxième chose très importante on
y a découvert sur cette comète des
molécules organiques qui acquis pourrait
avoir participé à lancement de nos
océans c'est à dire à l'introduction de
germes bactérien qui se sont multipliés
par la suite et qui ont favorisé
l'apparition de la vie après deux ans de
mission Rosetta c'est volontairement
écrasé sur la comète Choury en 2016 bon
je ne perds pas espoir pour vous faire
marquer des points dans ce quiz le
Latmos mais aussi des entreprises du
territoire contribuent directement à la
réussite de mission spatiale 3D plus qui
est installé à but qui a développé par
exemple la supercam dont les composants
ont été construits dans les Yvelines
regardez ces images supercam c'est un
outil majeur d'un Rover qui s'est posé
sur Mars en 2021 est-ce que vous vous
souvenez du nom de ce Rover martien donc
atterri qui a atterri sur Mars en 2021
je me souviens plus de surement mais je
sais que je l'ai lu quelque part un
petit indice à l'école conseil de classe
on vous dit quand on vous donne les
encouragements on vous dit que pour
continuer dans votre travail il faut il
y a un mot persévérer voilà donc c'est
persévérance
bonne réponse de la part de la team
Gabriel Laurent voilà premier point
marqué par cette team effectivement
persévérance le nom de ce Rover qui
s'est posé sur Mars le 18 février 2021
avec son petit drone ingénity qui nous a
donné les premières images aériennes de
mars la supercam a été développée dans
les Yvelines et a permis à persévérance
d'orienter son laser pour effectuer des
prélèvements du sol martien c'est un
outil majeur donc un 10 échantillons en
tout ont pu être prélevés ils sont
ramenés sur Terre en 2033 il faudrait
encore patienter grâce à une autre
mission alors l'objectif est majeur
c'est de détecter peut-être des
biosignatures dans ces échantillons
c'est à dire peut-être prouver qu'il y a
eu un jour de l'existence inexistence
sur sur la planète rouge une une vie qui
a pu exister sur cette planète rouge
pour la suite de ce quiz je vous propose
de regarder cet extrait c'est un lanceur
qui fait environ 20 mètres de haut un
diamètre d'1,7 m et qui pèsera 20 tonnes
au décollage on voit ici le premier
étage
qui est un étage qui comporte 9 moteurs
c'est un lanceur qui fonctionne à
l'oxygène liquide et au méthane et au
dessus on peut voir la coiffe et c'est à
cet endroit que seront accommoder les
satellites qui seront lancés par ce
lanceur
je vous présente Sirius 1 c'est un
lanceur spatial réutilisable 100%
français il n'y a pas que SpaceX et les
Américains qui ont monopole de ces
lanceurs Sirius 1 a été développé par
une start-up yvelinoise actuellement il
est en phase de développement ce lanceur
dans un laboratoire qui est situé dans
les Yvelines je vous demande tout
simplement dans quelle ville est situé
ce laboratoire le laboratoire donc de
l'entreprise siriuspace service
on n'est pas loin de lui en cours mais
c'est pas évident en cours
on est en dehors de l'agglomération de
50 ans en Yvelines à Buc c'est juste à
côté de Bu qu'une commune
une commune une commune à côté de Buc
les loges Les Loges-en-Josas très très
bonne réponse de Laurent agara voilà ça
fait deux points à zéro pour la team
Gabriel Laurent Les Loges-en-Josas à
Sirius 1 et justement en face de
développement dans ce laboratoire des
Loges jean-josas premier vol inaugural
prévu en 2025 depuis le centre spatial
de Kourou en Guyane allez une dernière
question pour vous refaire Mathilde et
essayer de revenir quoi qu'il arrive
vous avez perdu dans ce quiz mais vous
avez été toute seule vous avez été toute
seule donc voilà la défaite n'est pas
totalement méritée on va dire dans ce
quiz alors il y a une commune dans les
Yvelines que l'on surnomme la ville de
l'espace la ville de l'aéronautique et
de l'espace vous connaissez cette
commune Les Mureaux alors c'est pas
malheureusement l'objet de cette
question mais il y aura quand même un
bon point accordé peut-être à Laurent
Les Mureaux donc ville de l'espace de
par sa longue histoire alors déjà avec
l'aéronautique mais aussi avec de la
présence du siège d'un grand nom du
spatial sur son territoire quel groupe
justement est présent au bureau
c'est Ariane mais qui a changé de nom
et le troisième point pour le 3 0 dans
ce jeu
Gabriel Laurent leur plus pressé c'est
Ariane groupe un maître d'oeuvre des
familles de lanceurs européens Ariane 5
Ariane 6 dont il assure la conception et
l'ensemble de la chaîne de production le
site des Mureaux est en fait un site
historique il est présent sur place
depuis 1912 on parlait pas d'Ariane à
l'époque ça a été d'abord le berceau de
l'aviation française avant de se tourner
vers le spatial en 1965 il y a eu un
premier projet qui s'appelait diamant
c'était la première fusée le premier
lanceur français en dehors donc des
États-Unis et de l'ex-URSS puis le début
du programme Ariane s'était en 1970 plus
récemment Ariane a conclu un contrat
historique avec le géant Amazon ou alors
on parlait d'Amazon pour les livreurs il
y a un instant c'était en 2022 18
lancements de la fusée Ariane 6 conçu
donc au Mureaux vont être effectués dans
le cadre du projet Kuiper d'Amazon alors
le projet creep tout simplement c'est
une constellation de satellites qui va
être envoyée en orbite basse autour de
la Terre pour permettre à toute la
population de n'importe où sur terre on
pourra accéder à une connexion au débit
une connexion Internet au début donc ça
a été conclu l'année dernière en 2022
voilà merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
Laurent Laurent qui a donné pas mal de
bonnes réponses 3-0 mais vous étiez
toute seule aujourd'hui
on va essayer de faciliter la chose la
semaine prochaine
il y a des thèmes qui sont un peu plus
faciles que d'autres en tout cas merci
beaucoup Grégory kamelet c'est bientôt
la fin de cette émission mais juste
avant de se quitter je vous propose de
jeter un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo
de demain
[Musique]
matin la pluie sera bien présente sur
une bonne partie des Yvelines seul le
secteur de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines restera au
sexe selon Météo France au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 5 degrés à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles dans
l'après-midi la pluie s'étend sur tout
le département et côté température
comptez environ 8 à 7 degrés en moyenne
et pour les prévisions météo de ce
week-end c'est désormais notre Mister
météo Thomas Fletcher qui prend les
commandes il s'est baladé du côté de
Maurepas pour ce nouveau numéro alors
quoi de beau regarder
alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors quoi de beau ce week-end ce
dimanche c'est la fête des numismates
donc pour leur rendre hommage on va
faire un petit pile ou face si je fais
pile je présente pas la météo si je fais
face je la présente
pile
c'est pile non
ça c'est pile donc la météo voilà on est
parti on va refaire un pile ou face pour
le deuxième jour de la météo c'est
reparti
ok on commence parce que c'était pas
pile
mais faut que je fasse pile pour pas
présenter
ah fil je présente pas la météo des deux
jours vous avez le temps de la voir
normalement on va donc partir à votre
rencontre pour savoir si vous savez ce
que c'est un numismate pile ou face j'y
vais
pile
j'y vais pas
alors est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est
un numismat monsieur absolument pas en
quoi un quoi un numismate
des pièces de monnaie non ouais c'est un
collectionneur de pièces monsieur ah oui
effectivement on va faire un pile ou
face parce qu'en fait dimanche c'est la
journée des numismate
donc ça c'est ça c'est face ça c'est
pile ou face
[Rires]
c'est très bon merci beaucoup allez le
gag et pile vous dites
face OK
bah bien joué
[Rires]
de la joie
vous êtes contents
dommage
vous avez perdu le droit de rejouer
on l'a fait pour de vrai
est-ce que ça vous dit de jouer un pile
ou face non
je n'aime pas jouer
c'est quoi ça
c'est j'ai des faces
[Rires]
on fait un pile ou face madame
ok je comprends bonne journée
dommage
merde
du coup il a
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai perdu surtout
ben le droit de rejoindre
[Rires]
pas des questions essentielles tout à
l'heure ça dépend de l'accrophie
nécrophile moi j'ai rien compris
alors quoi de beau
et alors un plateau est-ce que vous
saviez ce que c'était aussi un numismate
ou pas
il en fait des études d'histoire la nuit
missmatie oui je j'avais déjà entendu ce
terme
non moi j'avais
vraiment encore beaucoup de
collectionneurs
et puis on va se quitter sur ça c'est la
fin de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]